use the associative law of
multiplication to write and here they
have 12 times 3 in the parentheses and
then we want they want us to multiply
that times 10 in a different way
simplify both expressions to show they
have identical results so the way that
they wrote it is let me just rewrite it
so they have 12 times 3
in parentheses and then they multiply
that times 10. now whenever something is
in parenthesis that means do that first
so this literally says let's do the 12
times 3 first now what is 12 times 3
it's 36
so this evaluates to 36 and then we
still have that times 10 over there
times 10 and we know the trick whenever
we multiply something times a power of
10 we just add the number of zeros that
we have at the back of it so this is
going to be
360. this is going to be equal to 300
and
now the associative law of
multiplications once again sounds like a
very fancy thing all that means is it
doesn't matter how we associate the
multiplication or it doesn't matter how
we put the parentheses we're going to
get the same answer so let me write it
down again
if we were to do 12 times 3
times
if we just wrote it like this without
parentheses we just went left to right
that would that would essentially be
exactly what we just did here on the
left but the associative law of
multiplication says you know what we can
multiply the 3 times 10 first and then
multiply the 12 and that's we're going
to get the exact same answer as if we
multiply the 12 times the 3 and then the
10. so let's just let's just verify it
for ourselves
so 3 times 10
3 times 10 is 30 and we still want to
multiply the 12 times that that was 12
times 30 and we've seen this several
times before you can view it as a 12
times 3
which is 36 but we still have this 0
here so that is also equal to 360. so it
didn't matter how we associated the
multiplication you could do the 12 times
3 first or you could do the 3 times 10
first either way they both evaluated to
360.